字幕: Akiko Kamio
校正: Kazunori Akashi
皆さん こんにちは
私は 浅野目と申します
私は 福祉活動家です
福祉活動家というのは
TEDxSapporoの方が
ネーミングしてくれました
ちょっと気に入っているので これからそれで
やってみようかなあと思ってます
福祉の仕事をしてます
福祉になぜ関わったかというと
ボランティアです
たまたま25年ぐらい前に
新聞で ボランティア募集というのがあって
ちょっとやってみるかな
みたいな気持ちでした
それで「１回やって楽しかったなあ」で
終わるつもりでした
だけどそのとき一緒にやった人に
「一回じゃわからない事ってあるよ」
「続けないと見えない事って
あるから」と言われて
なかなか続けるものがなかった私にとって
その言葉がちょっと大きくて
「ちょっと続けてみるかな」で続け
今まで何だかんだと言いながら続いています
この続けるってことで
見える事も確かにあるんですよね
自分の考えが色々変わってきました
まず まだボランティアを始めた頃に
ススキノのロックンロールのバーで
チャリティーコンサートを
やったことがあります
隣にストレッチャーっていう
ベッドのような車いすに乗っている
男の子がいました
この彼は違います
この彼は 今うちで織物の仕事を
してくれている彼です
うちの会社のヘルパーを連れて
パンクロックに行ったり
タトゥーを入れに行ったり
髪を染めに行ったりしてます
ちなみに 今はターコイズブルーの
髪の毛をしています
そのボランティアに行った時の彼は
もっともっと重い障害で よだれ垂らしてて
宙を見てて 音楽なんか
聞こえていないんじゃないか
分かっていないんじゃないかと
私は思っていました
お母さんが「この子 音楽大好きなんだよね」
とか 言っても
「それってただお母さんの自己満足で
彼はうるさいところに連れてこられて
可哀想に」くらい思ってました
だんだん盛りあっがてきて
皆ダンスを踊り始めたので
私はその彼の手を握って
踊りました
そしたら その彼の片方の手の中指だけが
きっちりとリズムを刻んでいたんです
私はものすごいショックだったんです
音楽なんて全然わかっていない
聞こえていないと思っていたその彼
ちゃんと分かってて 音楽を楽しんでて
こっちのこと全部伝わっているんだって
凄いショックでした
それから意識がない
寝たきりだって言われる人にも
こっちの気持ちって伝わっているんだ
聞こえているんだ 分かっているんだって
思うようになりました
もしかしたら 動物とか植物にも
本当は伝わっているのかもしれません
私の団体は 札幌の雪祭りの時に
ボランティアの派遣 運営をしている団体です
今はそれ以外にも いろいろ活動してますけど
私はだんだん運営の方の
仕事になってきたので
文句ばっかりボランティアさんに言われるし
責任とらされるのは私だし
「なんで私ばっかりやってんだろう」
「何のために私こんな事やってるんだろう」
「もう辞めるかなあ」と思ってた頃に
１本電話がきました
「ボランティア お願いします」
私はボランティアさんに
そのお宅まで行って 雪祭りを見てもらって
また帰ってきてもらうという
コーディネートをしました
その後すぐに手紙がきました
手紙には その奥さんから
「介護を10年間続けていました
買い物の時も急いで帰ってくるくらい
後はずっと２人きりで生活していました
出掛けるのは病院に行くとき以外
どこにも行ったことはありませんでした
雪まつりは本当に楽しかったです
ボランティアさんに家まで送ってもらって
ドアを開けた後 主人が私に
ありがとうと言ってくれました
10年間1度も言って
もらえなかった言葉でした
本当にありがとうございました
出掛ける自信がつきました
これから２人で 色んな所に出掛けたいと
思います」というお手紙でした
私はそのご夫婦には会っていません
ボランティアもしてないし
でも私は凄い嬉しかったんです
何かやっててよかった
ちょっと大変でも—
凄い大変だったんですが
それでも何か こんなちょっと良い事があったら
続ける甲斐があるなあと思って
もうちょっと続けてみるかなと思いました
そのご夫婦とは 会った事がないし
私はそのご夫婦から貰った元気で
今もまだ仕事を続けている事を
そのご夫婦はまったく知らない
でも私はそのご夫婦に いつも感謝してます
最近「ペイフォワード」っていう言葉
聞いたことありませんか
映画にもなりました
調べてみると
「先に支払う」
あと「親切にしてもらう前に親切にする」
「親切にしてもらった人とは
別の人物に 別の親切をする」
そんな意味があるそうです
私はそんなことを もっとずっと前に
体験したことがありました
まだ 子育てで大変な時 凄い大変だった時
知らない女性がやってきて
「いいよ 赤ちゃん見ていてあげるよ」
と言われました
知らない人だったし
「いやいや 大丈夫です
自分でやれます」と言ったら
その人が「大丈夫よ
私も子供が小さい時
知らない人に手伝ってもらったの
今はそのお礼をしているの
お礼させて」
「その代わりあなたが子育てを終わった時に
誰か大変そうなお母さんを 手伝ってあげて」
私そんなお礼の仕方ってあるんだなあと
その時思ってました
今で言う ペイフォワードですよね
日本では昔「恩送り」と言って
江戸時代には 普通に行われていた事だそうです
恩送り
その名残で「情けは人のためならず」という
諺があるそうです
「情けは人の為ならず」
情けを掛けると その人の為にならない
と私は思っていて
厳しい事があると
「情けは人の為ならず」と言って
優しくしないと言う風にしていたんだけど
逆の意味でした
情けを掛けることは
その人の為だけじゃなくて
自分や周りに 良い事なんだよって言う意味
この中にもそうだったのかって
思う人いませんか
それが恩送り
恩返しっていうのは簡単なんだと思います
何かやってもらった人にお礼をする
何か貰えばお返しする
私のお友達に もの凄いお金持ちがいて
私にいっぱい 高級品をくれる人がいます
こんな小さいキャビア １個１万円を５個とか
そうすると「私はこんなに貰っても
返せないわ」って言ったら
彼女が「違う違う
私あなたといると 凄い楽しいから
そのお礼に頂き物のおすそ分けを
しているだけだから気にしないで」って
言ってもらって それからは遠慮なく
もらっていますが
（笑）
だけど なんか品物やお金じゃなく
時間でも返せる事ってあるんだなって
その時ちょっと思いました
でも恩返しって白ヤギさんと
黒ヤギさんの歌のように
２人いる間は続くかもしれないけど
どっちかがいなくなっちゃったら
終わりのものですよね
恩返し
だけど「恩送り」というのは
もし自分がスタートだとしたら
ちょっと 貰えるものはないかもしれない
でもその代わりちゃんと送ることが出来たら
それは永遠に
世代を超えて続くものじゃないかな
と思います
また ちょっと子育ての時に
話は戻りますけど
私がその子育てで大変な時
両親はブラジルにいたので
子どもと荷物を持って
しょっちゅうブラジルに行っていました
凄い荷物いっぱいで
あの頃だから「新巻き鮭
３本持ってこい」とか 訳がわからない
（笑）
言われて それを持って子供２人連れて
行っていたんだけども
海外ではどこも困らなかった
みんな手伝ってくれたし 荷物運んでくれたし
知らない人も
１回 バスに乗って
後ろの席しか空いてなかったから
後ろの席に子供と行ったら
皆が前に乗れ 前に乗れって言うんです
仕方なく前に行ったら
前の人は 普通に席を替わってくれました
はいはい ここに座ってと
そして「前に乗った方が早く降りれて
いいでしょう」って
「後ろに乗ったら時間掛かるでしょう」
「あなたが早く降りれて良いでしょう
そして バスもそれだけ
早く出発できて良いでしょう」って
親切って 効率的な事でもあるんだなあって
ちょっとその時 思いました
やっと日本に着いて
ところが 日本では誰も
手伝ってくれませんでした
荷物なんか持ってくれる人はいないし
席なんか替わってくれる人なんか全然居なくて
その頃日本て 私は最低だなと
もう大嫌いでした
将来は もう日本から出ようと思うぐらい
ただ １回だけ自分１人でバスに
乗ったことがあったんです
途中から杖をついたおじいちゃんが
歩くのもやっとでバスに乗ってきました
私よりはちょっと
離れたところに立ったのですが
その横にいる若い男の子は
まったくよける気配はなく
その周りの人も 誰もよける気配はなく
あたしはこっちで「替わってあげればいいのに
やっぱり日本て最低」
じゃあ いざ自分が替わろうと思ったら
私も言えませんでした
なんか ここから歩いって行って
席替わりますよと言うのが
偽善者のように思われるのではないか
年寄り扱いするなと
怒られるんじゃないかとか
なんか だんだん次の駅で降りるのかもとか
リハビリに頑張ってるのかもとか
なんだか訳が分からないことを思いながら
なんだか替われなかったです
そして 自分で物凄い凹みました
何だ私も言えないんだ
もうひとつは なんであの時
自分から 替わって下さいって
言わなかったんだろう
きっと替わって下さいと言ったら
替われたんじゃないかなって
なんでだろう
日本人て とても恥ずかしがりやで
他人に何か 声を掛けるのが苦手なのかなと
あと 手伝って下さいって言いづらかったり
手伝いますよ 席替わりますよと
慣れていないので 何て言っていいか分からない
どうしていいか分からないだけなのかなと
その時思いました
じゃあ どうしたらいいのだろうと
私は私なりに考えて
ああそうか まず手伝ってくださいとか
席替わって下さいって言う人を
増やせばいいんだ
手伝ってとか 席替わってと言われたら
分かりましたよと 替われる—
替わることに慣れてもらえば良いのかなと
特別な事ではなくなれば 良いのかなと
その頃思いました
今もそうやって 色んな人に出掛けてもらって
声を掛けていったり 席を替わってもらったり
そんな社会ができたらいいなと思って
今もずっと活動を続けています
もう20年超えましたが
最近 全然変わりました
結構 席替わってくれます
手伝いますかと 声を掛けてもらえます
時々これ私のお陰かなと
ちょっと思うくらいです
（笑）
その恩送り
私にしたら きっとその福祉の仕事は
たまたまきっかけがあって
こういう仕事をしていて
それで できる事なのかなと思うのですが
皆さんもなんでもいいから一つ
恩送りしてみたらどうでしょう
自分で何が出来るのか 思いつかなかったら
私はなんだか楽しそうにしてるだけでも
それは恩送りになるのではないかと思うんです
この写真—
楽しそうじゃないですか
福祉の仕事って大変で
辛いという話があるので
福祉の仕事したいっていう人
今 凄い少ないんです
深刻なんです
でもこんな風に楽しそうに
している写真見るだけで
なんか自分もやってみたいな なんて
思ってくれるんじゃないかな と
そしたらここで楽しそうにやっている人たちは
自分達では意識してないのかもしれないけど
でもなんかちょっと 役に立っているのでは
ないかと思います
その恩送り
自分では ちゃんと送れてるのか
分からないかもしれない
そのご夫婦は その手紙がこんなにも
私に元気をくれている事を全く知りません
自分の恩送りが どういう風に
伝わっているのかは わからないかもしれない
でも まず自分が恩送りをした
それだけで今 自分がいる意義というものが
出来上がるんじゃないでしょうか
その後 送っていく事っていっぱいあるけども
まず自分が送り出す それだけで
随分違うんじゃないかなと思います
この「楽しい」って—
皆がいつでも楽しいかって言ったら
そんな事はないですよね
どんなに心の中で楽しいと思っても
楽しそうに見えなかったら意味がない
逆にちょっとあまり楽しくなくても
楽しそうにしていれば それは意義が
あるのではないかなと
良いと思った事を
ちょっとだけ楽しそうにやってみる
ちょっと意識してみる
私もいろいろ大変で もう何だろうなという事
今でも一杯あります
でもそんな時でも ちょっと意識するだけで
気持ちは全然違うんだと思うし
そこから必ず自分の周りが変わっていきます
それは断言できます
その後 またそれを送っていくと
それはどんどん広がっていく事だと思います
ぜひいっしょに—
私は福祉 でも皆は違う事でも
全然構いません
自分の所からそんな恩送りしていけたら
良いなと思います
今日はどうもありがとうございました
（拍手）